autre start-up incubé ici au sein du ski
cube elle a rejoint l'incubateur de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et en 2021
c'est affleia et nous sommes avec la
dirigeante et fondatrice de cette
start-up Dominique renard Brazi bonjour
bonjour Nicolas
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
bah déjà pourquoi avoir rejoint le ski
cube en fait quand on est fonda quand on
est fondatrice comme ça d'une start-up
du dans un projet entrepreneurial on a
vraiment besoin d'être accompagné sur
des domaines qu'on maîtrise moins c'est
mon cas c'était le commerce le marketing
etc et on a besoin en fait d'être
accompagné sur sur ces sujets là ce
qu'on est un peu un peu seul en fait
dans quand on est dans ce type de projet
alors afflelia est spécialisée dans
l'économie circulaire dans le secteur du
bâtiment oui c'est ça nous notre mission
c'est de simplifier en fait le passage à
l'économie circulaire dans la dans le
secteur du bâtiment et de simplifier la
l'utilisation des ressources sur les
chantiers de déconstruction et de
démolition donc on a développé akibo
c'est un assistant digital au futur
diagnostic peemd produit équipement
matériaux de déchets en fait c'est une
obligation réglementaire qui va
apparaître normalement
prochainement pour en fait faire
l'inventaire de tous les matériaux sur
les chantiers de déconstruction et
essayer de mieux les valoriser alors du
coup là maintenant grâce au ski cube
vous en êtes où quel est l'avenir du
coup et qu'est ce que vous attendez
encore du ski cul parce que vous êtes
encore incubé alors on a commencé en
fait en 2022 ça a été vraiment l'année
de la commercialisation et
l'enrichissement de l'outil donc tout le
contact avec les clients les démarches
marketing les réflexions business model
et là j'ai pu effectivement bénéficier
de l'accompagnement du ski cube pour ces
travaux qui sont qui sont vraiment
importants et et assez compliqué et donc
2023 et 2023 bah normalement
en tout cas c'est laisser les vœux là
puisqu'on est en début d'année de de
poursuivre l'accélération et en fait de
passer l'échelle c'est-à-dire que là
pour l'instant la commercialisation elle
est auprès de de quelques acteurs qui
sont plutôt pilotes et précurseurs et
après il faut passer à l'échelle aller
trouver d'autres modes de
commercialisation et là aussi on est en
réflexion avec avec les acteurs de ce
qui cube incubAlliance etc merci
beaucoup Dominique merci